as well in this actual game and we can
see now that uh Evancho has played porn
D4 in his first move what kind of a plan
do you and Magnus have in this game I
think generally my concept is that when
I play when my guy I'm coaching plays
evanchook I'm not capable of predicting
what eventually does I think one point
with vision and then in Bilbao in a
tournament I checked that Evancho had
played 15 difference opening against
anan's E4 so I prepared something for
everything and he played opening number
six teams against Vichy and after that
experience I just realized I cannot
predict eventually and yeah that's
that's life so are you just gonna lean
back now Peter and enjoy this great game
between two uh Legends I think so I
think this is a game that should be
enjoyed for for a lot of reasons so I
will do that
sharing your thoughts we really
you're welcome thank you
all right well Peter said it this is the
game to look forward to and uh it has
started ivanship with the white pieces
is it something uh crazy and unexpected
uh not necessarily crazy right now but
possibly unexpected Magnus is the first
one to think he's uh paused now for
almost one minute
um this night move it's it's known but
uh maybe not the most popular move in
the position
and uh yeah I'm I'm pretty sure Magnus
wouldn't have looked at this uh this
move this morning at least or not for a
long time and that's why he's just
deciding what move to choose now how to
continue and do either of you two have
experience with this one
no I must be honest I don't have any
experience but when I'm checking the
database I can see the top
rated purse person thing that has played
it is stockfish oh with a with a Gods
rating of
3617 yes isn't it he's better than God
well it's better than God yes yeah it's
not really an animate object is it so we
had this discussion yesterday that um
Ken said that if if God had a ELO rated
it'd be 3600 yeah that's stockfish
stockfish is three thousand six and six
hundred and Seventeen hang on I've got
Komodo dragon is 3 609 and uh yeah so
they're better than God not Leela Siro
for apparently as of 2012 that was 2020.
something's gone wrong here they can't
be done they just can't it's not it's
not possible rights of the machines
they're taking over yeah everything
so all right well these two two uh
Legends uh Magnus Carlsen is uh the
closest human to being God in uh chess's
highest rated player in the world with a
big smile on his face he's uh probably
enjoying playing the legend vasley one
Shook and they have played each other so
many times these two and Evancho has
beaten Magnus several times we do have
some interesting head-to-head scores in
Rapid chess
look at this
15 wins in the history of Rapid chess
for Ivan Shook and uh 13 wins for Magnus
so Ivan shook it's got the upper hand
yeah and that's a lot of decisive games
as well a few draws but I mean who beats
Magnus once in their lifetime let alone
15 times and this is just the rapid as
well
um so he's got a track record as Peter
heiner mentioned he's outplayed Magnus
even more times than he's beaten him and
uh yeah I mean we're in for a really
fascinating battle I I am slightly
worried that Ivan trick after his start
to today uh will struggle slightly but
this opening seems to have caught Magnus
off guard and Magnus did spend three
minutes eventually pushing a pawn just
keeping things solid
I vaguely remember studying this move
years and years ago and I thought it was
quite provocative I thought this would
allow white to gain space in the center
at some point but yeah maybe at least
Magnus wants to get a ventric thinking
for himself and get him out of his
preparation
okay early days fantric what will the
genius yeah show us now I can tell you a
very quick and this is a very natural
move I mean just asking the Bishops
where it's going to go in Magna style
decides to keep the bishop and as you
say David he's moved in the center so
we're pretty pretty normal at the moment
I guess considering position but I can
tell you a very quick nice really nice
Evancho story
um I was playing the European Club cup
with my team which was um Dukes of Kent
and I was bored one we're over in Israel
in a place called elat on the south of
Israel and my team was mainly uh players
of about 21 2200 strength we're sitting
in the bar surprisingly enough we're
outside a bar all eight of us looking at
our games on the board this little mini
chess set and the team captain Chris
Rice was uh showing his game and
everyone was kabitzing saying Chris why
didn't you just play that and he was
getting so annoyed he was like oh just
shut up just shut up I want to look at
the game and it was like you could have
just played that then all of a sudden
someone you know someone moved a piece
on the bodies I'll just leave it alone
shut up and he looks around it as a
venture
and Chucky had just walked over and just
seen a chessboard seen us looking at
chess and he was just being quietly like
a quiet assassin behind us and he'd just
come in and he just came in and he just
started he joined us and he just joined
us because he loves chess so much and
Chris was like oh my oh my words did I
just tell Chucky to shut up and I was
like oh sorry Chucky you can join us if
you want to and Chucky sat down and he
was analyzing for us and he was just
talking chess you know with us all and
we weren't the strongest chess players
you know you know in general we're some
of the weakest players there but he just
loves chess so much he just sat there
and he just joined in you know with us
talking to us for about an hour or so is
that's how much he loves it you know so
yeah it was nice really nice you could
see you know just how human he is as
well with that so
yeah no no for Chucky you know chass is
like an art you know it's something to
be enjoyed and uh talking about art Rich
de Silvio sends us a tweet where it
shows us a painting well so
with chess pieces it's very very nice I
like it and if you two want to send in
your chest pictures your selfies your
thoughts your questions then remember to
tweet us using the hashtag chess Champs
and we will feature them on the show
yeah
the artistic Yvonne shook still with
more than 15 minutes on the clock Magnus
is down to a little less than 11 minutes
so has he been surprised in the opening
here by one shook he's been surprised
but normally even when Magnus is
surprised he'll kind of recompose
himself after 30 seconds one minute and
he'll move but I think this is just the
respect he has for evanchook really
slowing Magnus down and uh there are a
few moves he can play the black king can
Castle to safety very natural move the
black light Square Bishop can come out
um black can trade a set of Pawns in the
center there's a bunch of options maybe
that's why Magnus is just taking time to
pick between
uh just to see kind of what his
instincts tell him but okay he does
Castle the safest move in the end and uh
that clock advantage that five minute
advantage that ventric has now he needs
to maintain it he needs to keep it uh we
did see that uh several times now in
this tournament when he drops lower on
the clock the blunders uh have slipped
into his game but uh yeah right now I
love the opening choice just keeping
pieces on the board it's not going to be
kind of a slow uh kind of grind it's not
going to be a boring end game I just
want to see these two really go at each
other
and evantric White's priority now is to
try and get the king to safety White's
King is still stuck in the middle a
couple of moves away from castling
yeah interestingly enough I I've taken
out the database and I can see the top
player who's played this um there's
actually Alexi Serrano and he played
against Arjun eragisi
and uh unfortunately Serrano lost
it was a with white this was played
quite recently a few months ago in May
and there white tried to do what you
suggested you know I tried to kind of
unravel the King by developing the
knights but uh here well well well
eventually it goes for a much more
creative approach instead he's
threatening to push the B Pawn forward
and trap the bishop but Magnus he
quickly spots that and develops the
Knight covering the B4 square and I like
this move by Yvonne Chuck it's
unorthodox it's unusual and he's kind of
maybe making a square for his King to
run to but maybe well I think they're
much more important ideas perhaps to
step the E Pawn one square forward
yeah I mean it looks like he's really
neglecting his peace development though
inventric Simon what do you think about
this move
yeah I was going to say the same I I I
mean I I'm not sure I'd like it that
much because
um there is a real problem as you as you
just summed up there David I mean like
look at White's King look at White's
pieces I mean look at Black's King
already castled Black's opening up the
position somewhat and this to me seems
very dangerous or white it might be okay
but the king's gonna take free moves to
Castle you have to move the Knight the
bishop the king so three moves to get
your king safe and that's a lot of moves
so black has basically three moves to
gain initiative and he's done that so
he's uh and the king is wandering so but
I I guess if white can maintain the
center he's going to be doing all right
but can he do that David here do you
think I mean uh with that move wow I
mean if it pays off if he gets time as
you mentioned Simon to start pushing
Thorns forward in the center maybe
moving his Knight on the next turn
then we'll start praising a ventric but
uh if it goes wrong then we will start
blaming this setup with the King
kind of out in the open now uh
definitely don't try this at home kids
don't move your king out before the rest
of your army but maybe it just needs to
be done a Magnus is ideal with this last
move I guess was to push forward but uh
this is just going to be an exchange of
Pawns black can choose three different
captures here but I mean the question is
where to put this Knight maybe you have
to park it on the edge of the board
somewhere and already it just looks like
it's really opening up
um the reason I suggest this Square for
the White Knight is because otherwise
the black Bishop might come and start
harassing this white king at least now
if the bishop enters this uh Square it
can be chopped off by the White Knight
but yeah I mean it's it's really playing
with fire and uh the position whether it
becomes open on the next move or not uh
maybe black can just wait for example
with a rook uh yeah white skin is going
to be an eternal Danger
another idea quite typical for these
types of openings is for the Black
Knight to move out the way at some point
the black queen to jump out with some
checks or maybe at least to stop pushing
this point forward I don't think this is
going to happen yet but uh like this
happens in the names of Indian and the
opening we're looking at right now quite
frequently
and okay Magnus does just keep the
tension he moves his Rook across and
okay eventually has to play with haste
get this Knight out the way get this
bishop out the way at least pretend that
you've got active pieces
that's not such an easy thing to do when
you've developed your pieces in such a
weird way I mean like how are you going
to get that like squared wish about you
where is that Knight gonna go I mean
questions questions because it's never
been seen before
it's like are you gonna I guess one of
these two squares
um this looks like a different variation
if a different branch of the nimso
Indian uh where White Knight usually
uses this Square I guess sometimes it
can jump forward into the dream F5 post
uh at least it opens up this bishop
potential attack against this Pawn
meanwhile Magnus his last move has
hinted that he wants to kind of maintain
this Pawn where it is and he'll push
forward with this one creating a square
for the Black Knight but what is a
ventric doing breaking the rules David
I mean look at this diagonal now okay
Magnus just pushes a pawn but this
diagonal if a black piece ever lands
here this king is going to be in so much
trouble
I've got to say I would never ever play
like this with white but if he gets away
with it so can Magnus just move his
Queen for example yeah the next move
exactly uh yeah you might uh be right
Kaya either I'm not sure which one's
best the bishop to this square or the
queen to this square and then uh for
example if let's say white makes a silly
move uh then if this Pawn pushes forward
this bishop is going to give a check or
the queen is going to use that square
like you mentioned and
deadly deadly times uh it's gonna be
hard for white to survive so big moment
for a ventric he needs something quick
okay he puts his Bishop on this diagonal
at least at least blocking any potential
checks
but uh Magnus he's gonna possibly push
one of these two pawns or uh maybe move
this Knight out the way
start opening things up towards the my
king yeah I was gonna I was gonna just
say that plan as well David you've
mentioned using uh using a lever to open
up your opponent's king because the only
thing that's protecting White's King
he's got this lovely Pawn what we call a
pawn chain it's like a bike chain right
all those pawns are like guarding each
other and they block all the files
towards White's King so often when you
see your opponent has a pawn chain like
that you need to break the chain
Breakers bite down and that's why
David's moving the night move gets ready
to throw the pawn forwards and try to
break that chain so I I like this move a
lot which which he's played just getting
ready to attack and uh you know I will I
expect to move his G Pawn now knowing
knowing Chucky now you know so just to
try and stop that plan but it just looks
so dangerous for white because white is
not fully developed and it's his King
you know look at that King it looks so
scary on that square if you could swap
it around and kind of plant it in the
corner where this Rook is then you'll be
very happy
King is still a mile away and the
problem is you can't really drop it The
King back to safety because then your
Rook is just stuck for the next 15 20
moves for this foreseeable future so uh
yeah it's it's not looking like that's
an easy solution uh you mentioned the
assignment that if a ventric is
consistent and ambitious which he
clearly has been uh so far then he might
take it to the extremes and just push
his Pawn forward clamping down on this
square and giving his King another
Square it might need to move to but
again all these moves come with risks
because you're yeah you're loosening
your position so so white does have a
very loose position but if he can
maintain it and finish his development
he will be better because that pawn
chain it gives him a strategic Advantage
I mean he's got the better Pawn
structure just not the better pieces so
it's kind of that as a fight between the
pawns and the pieces here yeah I I agree
I like your idea Simon it's kind of bold
my Approach would have been actually to
not play so risky even though I do love
my Pawn pushes I would maybe develop the
Knight to the G3 square and then you
know I maybe make a move that you know
hopefully would be proud of Simon push
the H Pawn why not go for it yeah yeah
as far up the board as that can go yeah
after all we're breaking the rules oh
you might as well keep breaking him I
guess exactly yeah
but uh he has played your move there
your van can move at night and um Magnus
has now played that other mood that
David mentioned and giving himself some
good squares for his pieces yeah this
one's shaping up to be a fascinating
battle it's just a clash of ideologies
that's white going for the long term
thinking as Simon mentioned I have to
put a pawn structure I have great
squares for my pieces it's just I need
the time to get them there and Magnus is
going to be
trying to just be the destructor and
he's going to try and create chaos
before white is fully mobilized
I mean yeah they're two courageous
players these two much more courageous
than most of us
I think it's easier playing Black in
these positions you know you've got to
think about who's got the easier moves
to play often not who's better but whose
position is just more you know easier to
you know play the right things and here
black can just put his pieces on good
squares moving towards the king trying
to swap off some of whites good
Defenders and open up the position it's
kind of as simple as that on the other
hand White's got to think right how do I
get my king safe how do I get my rook in
the game where do I put my Bishop
there's many more problems for white to
overcome here and that that means it's
like you know it's like a Minefield uh
for white and okay he's lunged there
with a pawn trying to take some squares
I guess away from Black's pieces David
yeah but this Pawn can be captured on
passant has he forgotten about on
Passover
yeah a bit of grip one yes yeah this
Pawn could be captured as if it just
moved one square by the black Pawn on C4
uh maybe we'll show what Chucky has in
mind it does feel very risky we
mentioned that black wants to use this
Square for a night his Knight is
currently terrible uh so Chucky pushes
the spawn forward if Magnus ignores it
and drops his Bishop back also a very
sensible move then at least this Knight
is sidelined
for the near future but the question is
at this point it just moved two squares
it cannot bypass the black pawn which
sits on the black fifth Rank and you can
take it off the board
now you attack the Knight as well what
is White's intention is he gonna take
back this Pawn I
it looks ugly if you take back this Pawn
with the queen of Rook then black gains
even more time bringing the Knight
forward to a great Square hitting the
White Queen is his idea really to just
um kind of ignore this very strong pawn
and take here with the white knight I
mean again it's so brave it's so loose
but maybe there's nothing wrong with it
maybe there's no way for black to punish
look how much time as well Magnus is
burning on the clock because if antrik
is surprising him on every turn with
these weird wacky moves and uh if your
opponent surprises you it's human nature
to pause
fascinating battle right now this night
defended by the white Bishop
I don't know it does feel like the event
check is taking liberties with his
position
and well we're going to see what does he
have in store
is he going to play it safe I personally
will probably grab that pawn with the
queen but no he's gone for it he's
allowing black a huge past Pawn on the
third row
this is crazy stuff now
he just wants to win this Pawn on the
next move Adventure after Breaking All
the Rules putting his King I mean not
castling first of all putting his King
on the Square wasting time with
development he's just going to be greedy
and go Pawn hunting maybe win this Pawn
uh maybe sorry win at this point as well
is greed good I don't know um this Pawn
is also attacked he's threatening to win
three different pawns but it's all about
the white king if black can somehow push
pieces to the other side of the board it
might not survive
the bar is inching up for Magnus Carlsen
in this game
is it hard to understand the plan
eventually
and now is to just win spawns
um long-term assignment mentioned the
black porn structure is inferior white
has the beautiful structure everything
long term now is great for white so I
think his plan is to just be as
ambitious as maximalist as possible
right now and then just survive until
the end game when he can convert that
Advantage Magnus it's all about short
term he needs to do something before
I mean if White's Bishop light Square
Bishop comes out if White's Rook from
the corner comes out it's just game over
white is going to have an advantage yeah
because I have to say apart from that
very far Advanced black porn the black
pieces look a little bit uh defensive I
mean they're all you know bunched up
yeah bunched up and towards the back
ranks yeah they don't have any clear
purpose do they not yet they need to
start jumping out the Black Knights need
to start centralizing I think he's just
got to go for it I mean this break we
mentioned the F the Freddy porn
um would be a lovely you call it a lever
as we said to get rid of the pawn chain
that is I I'm looking at that move you
can't play it yet but if you move your
knight you can get ready to play it I
mean just play you know both sides of
playing with fires move your knight
right into the center of the board and
then just try to move you know blast
open position somewhere that's what kind
of thing I'd be looking at if I was
black here at least you know open it up
quickly don't worry about your pawns
here if you're on the black side just
don't don't even look at how many pawns
have been attacked there's too many not
counting yeah I mean it's free porn
one's been attacked so don't even try to
defend you know that's not the right way
to look at this position the right way
to look at it is my opponent's king is
over there I need to open it up so let's
see how I can do that and we don't think
any defensive thoughts here
um so yeah the currency of this position
is definitely just open lines and active
pieces
and Magnus look at the clock time four
minutes
I think this might be the lowest uh or
the biggest time differential we've ever
seen uh Magnus on the wrong end of yeah
less than four minutes against eventrix
11. if you ask me beforehand to make a
prediction I would have said it would be
the other way around
okay Adventure he's not in pain he's
just calculating and that's his
calculating face head in the hands
and yeah I think they both look a little
bit worried in this game
yes yeah definitely I reckon they're
both enjoying it though I mean how often
do they get to play nowadays they played
a lot when they when they were a bit
younger
it's a okay the queen coming up we
didn't predict this very mysterious move
that one I mean uh that gets in the way
of the lever that we mentioned that pawn
that's behind the queen now I thought
was a key element for black I thought
black needed to use that pawn to open up
the king can you really attack the white
king enough just with your pieces or are
you going to try to change the queen
side now and try to use your B Pawn so
that that is a mysterious move and
actually the valuation bar now I mean I
think in this game don't look at the
evaluation part right because it's like
it's not helping and it's looking at it
it's not saying it's winning for either
side it's just saying okay maybe it
wasn't the best decision yeah uh but
yeah maybe you're right Simon this is
this Pawn is going to be pushed at some
point the queen does protect on this
diagonal so trying to keep this Pawn
alive maybe but lots of people will be
asking including myself
why does that porn have to stay alive
that's a good question
for example you can take it with a rook
I guess Magnus will just use this
opportunity to gain time now that a
piece has landed on the Square you can
gain time with his Knight but yeah I
mean I don't see anything wrong right
now with just retreating
just like a smash and grab you take the
pawn you run away
game goes on exactly I mean Magnus it
looks like there's a pin on this line
but you can't profit from it for example
this Pawn uh the white Pawn can't
capture because it's pinned but the
White Knight is safely protecting uh I
mean what could magnus's idea be it's so
mysterious I'm struggling to understand
if someone played this move against me I
would be just in complete shock for a
minute or two
it looks bizarre and the idea of getting
rid of that pawn is you know Ivanka you
mentioned it I think it's just so
natural because that is a scary Pawn you
know that's that's one point in your
side of the position just get rid of it
you know even you know let's let's see
what our opponent's plan is here uh but
I I expect now Chucky won't play that
right because it's like disgusting
because it's so obvious he'll do
something which is not so obvious and
wow they're in front of us we see the
best uh or the top computer suggestions
and actually taking this Pawn isn't one
of them the computer suggests I mean an
even more inhuman move taking this Pawn
what is this Pawn doing
um I guess the idea is to actually
reroute the Knight to a better Square to
an outpost on C6 and this is a nice post
for the White Knight but
I mean it just feels like a step too far
for humans if we explain the second top
computer move that makes some sense
jumping in with the white knight ganging
up on this Pawn With both nights now but
again it feels provocative it feels like
you've moved this night uh twice already
do you really want to move it a third
time while you're lagging behind in
development
I think the top two computer moves are
hard to see Knight takes pawn and Knight
to the scrap or they're not hard to see
but they're very hard to kind of believe
in I wonder what's wrong with this
Brooke takes Pawn now I'm like this must
be something wrong about me first or is
there I mean like I can't see it the
third move the third move is like what
on Earth
that's the Joker's move that is I mean
uh you know stop nothing wrong with this
stock fish and stockfish is apparently
stronger than God I'm sorry I don't
believe it not with moves like that so
um we'll never see this third move I
think this king Retreat that's not
Chucky style to play kind of this safe
kind of uh howardly approach nice type
of thing I might do but not for Chucky
will he played a computer's Top Choice
what do we reckon
um yes or no I mean I think you'll take
one of these pawns maybe this one but
also possibly this one the more I look
at it the more I think actually yeah
this one makes some sense it's a
beautiful Square for the White Knight
after he it's not winning the pawn it's
where it where it's going to go next and
that square protected by your Pawn is
just a beautiful Square you know your
knight is totally safe there controlling
many many uh good out many good outposts
yeah so I think it does make a lot of
sense actually the only downside is you
leave this Pawn in life and you might
even leave it on the second rank where
it ties down your pieces but he took it
in the wrong piece wow he took it with
the wrong piece we said it was not about
winning the pawn it was more about
planting your night in this Square he's
taking it with the bishop wow I see the
evaluation bar react it does and wow
look at what stockfish says this wasn't
the top computer recommendation but
Magnus he's happy to give up his Rook
wow he's trying to just get rid of this
white Bishop I guess he's happy to take
back and he'll use his dance squirt
Bishop
to uh dominate on those dark squares to
try and go for the white king what a
decision played instantly by Magnus
he finally predicted one of the ventrix
moves and in the current position if
white doesn't get greedy and take this
Rook I guess his Bishop is in risk of
getting trapped anyway
heating up even more wow
they're both playing so creatively yeah
every move I'm really impressed by
magnus's last move though that just that
shows such class just to voluntarily
just give away the rook and take in turn
the dark squares I I love it and I just
think White's position now is very very
dangerous I don't see even Chuck
surviving
in Practical terms if black can take
over the dark squares it's going to be
really dangerous for the white king so
he tries to offer a queen trade I like
this move because uh you know no matter
what the evaluation Bar says where you
know maybe black shouldn't exchange
Queens I certainly would not want to
exchange Queens if I could but when
you're in Danger get the Queens off it's
like when your King's in danger doubly
get the Queens off because it's the most
dangerous attacking peace so I I do
approve I think of of this idea at least
agree but I wouldn't want to exchange
Queens I want to I mean can I give a
whole Rook up this would be my first
thought might be absolute rubbish oh
he's exchange Queens yeah I was thinking
it was quite good because suddenly look
at that porn on B3 that is going to
become a monster and as long as it stays
on the board and stays on alive then
black will be better
then again uh White is one point up
temporarily if white can as you
mentioned even could get rid of that
black B3 Pawn at least he's surviving at
least uh he has long-term chances I'm
worried about that white Bishop still
that white Bishop is surely going to get
hit
I mean I yeah it's so hard to call maybe
there was just no safe Square for the
black queen as you mentioned Simon but
keeping the Queens on the board would
have been
kind of the most consistent approach
swapping Queens
surely if antrik's gonna survive and uh
okay the black Rook moves
I guess magnus's idea is that the white
Bishop has to trade itself off anyway
and black will still control the dark
squares
so can white now get rid of that
dangerous Pawn again you know if white
can get rid of that dangerous Pawnee I
don't know if he can actually but yeah
maybe we jump in and explain because
this bishop is uh trapped right now
um it's only Escape square is really to
go back and capture the Black Knight so
a trade and Simon you want to get rid of
this Pawn immediately makes a lot of
sense I don't see any reason not to I
guess black for example will just drop
the bishop back and
um still even though it's the end game
even though the Queens are off this king
is still not entirely happy for example
if there's a nitrate this track is very
annoying
no real great Square for the white king
if you step back then again you're going
to block the entrance of the game
entrance of this Rook into the game
and black will win a pawn back so black
will be only one point down now and this
bishop is the best piece on the board
controlling this whole diagonal this is
the problem with putting pawns on
light's Quest your dark squares become
very very weak
so evantric thinking yeah how important
is it for him to at least keep his time
Advantage now
very important I mean if we reach a
position like this one on the analysis
board then it's going to be so easy for
black to play
so right now we're expecting this one
but maybe a ventric looking for
Alternatives well he has had quite a few
surprises in this game already maybe we
should expect something uh strange yeah
yeah it's possible the White Knight
could go and protect that Bishop but
that feels like it's really really risky
looking at space
yeah he looks like he's getting some
divine inspiration though like yeah he's
talking to his pieces he's talking to
his white Bishop saying his or his dark
Squad Bishop saying where do you want to
go do you want to trade off I want to
keep you on the board but how do I do it
yeah he's one of a kind the world would
be a much sadder place without him
wouldn't it yeah he does really bring a
lot uh to to chess
yeah there is also that famous game from
Berlin World Blitz Championship when he
checkmated Magnus cross and he had that
jump when he realized he had put the
world to the champion Checkmate and
Magnus was Furious I wonder if we can
get I mean I'd love to see that what I
should I don't know I think I've seen it
but yeah yeah when he saw her the first
time I ever saw ventric uh I think I was
maybe six or seven years old and I was
watching a videotape like a VHS old
school videotape and it was some
commentary uh of a tournament it was a
series of Rapid tournaments and uh in
one position I think it was against
Anand he had a Checkmate in one move and
the commentators were like it's
Checkmate it's Checkmate and he's you
can see him staring at the board just
like he's looking he's looking and he's
getting frustrated he can't find the
move and he can just bring his Queen
into the corner and this game over and
he had like a couple of minutes on his
clock and then there's clocked it down
and down and down he had a few seconds
left and then he made a different move
he just didn't see it and he ended up
losing and uh and he was like literally
tearing his hair out afterwards and uh I
mean that was just for me that was the
moment I realized okay if Andrew he's he
has his ups and downs but he is a genius
and um actually in this famous memory
test that I had with Magnus last year I
put that position on the board Magnus
was like yep it's a an end against the
ventric 1994 and uh some Magnus even at
a young age he was studying Evancho's
games as well
um so she I mean he's playing one of his
chess Heroes I think everyone's just
here yeah do you think Magnus does have
a chess hero and who do you think it is
many uh I mean do you guys have a chess
hero I mean um
wow I want that some magic really sad if
you do but I don't know I mean like
anyone you really look up to because you
love that Simon don't you yeah I'd say
tau's my probably my chess here right
when I was growing up
um and I was really little you know I
grew up watching the Karl POF and
Kasparov matches and that was like super
interesting because we watched that yeah
we've watched that as a family yeah and
we used to go on tally texts and just
follow the moves but the people who I
really followed every single move of and
I read every single article I could
where of course the Polgar sisters I
loved them yeah and also someone British
a British late top female player called
uh Susan she was Susan Arco at the times
and then she became Susan lalit and I I
followed everything that she did and you
know she was such an idol of mine but
yeah they're all legends in the game
could you name one hero of yours uh uh
no I mean there's too many so many yeah
yeah I'll say cram Nick just I'll cram
just because he was at his Peak when I
was growing up yeah similar stylish yeah
as well simulation it based a lot of my
game on him yeah and now did we see
surprises from Evancho what's happening
on the board now we saw some surprises
they could get even more open now yeah
you're right Kaya that's that's the big
thing uh we did see the bishop trade
itself off for a night so black now has
full control over the dark squares that
black dark Square Bishop is going to be
the well potentially the MVP the most
valuable piece and meanwhile the white
king is trying to run away from its gaze
trying to run away from that dark Square
Bishop but the problem is what the black
Rook now can come down and take a pawn
okay first Magnus is trading off a set
of pieces
and uh White's light squared Bishop is
kind of hitting thin air blacks like uh
Black start score Bishop is also not
hitting anything right now but
it feels like it's got so much potential
and that black b-pawn the black B Pawn
is alive and it's very scary it's a past
one two squares away from promotion it
might even tie down a whole Rook
yeah still a very complicated position
and I have to say I am very scared for
Evancho you know part of me you know I
really want him to win I I know we're
meant to be like completely impartial or
neutral
if you manage to pull off something but
uh Magnus playing it safe defending the
pawn and still
Evan Chuck has to deal with a threat
against his a-born Connie now at least
get his Knight to that the other decent
Square now which looks like a nice plan
to me I mean we the night maybe has done
its job on the Square it is I mean they
say the square is a brilliant Square for
the night but only if you can back it up
I'd be bringing it to the queen side
here whoops sorry my Arris
um here you can give a check and when
the king moves this Square Simon this
yeah yeah I was just thinking it's
nicely protected by the pawn it stops a
black Rook getting behind uh the black
porn attacking the rook and um you know
I'm gaining some control over this
diagnosis
now this looks very nice for uh for
white I guess the Rick will move and
still a problem with this Pawn defending
it Patrick is going to come and take it
soon and still also how do you get rid
of this uh this guy if you can get
yeah that bee Pawn could be a game when
I just it's so hard and Black's night is
actually fantastic as well because it's
guarding it and there's Duo right yeah
yeah would you ever get rid of them yeah
but somehow you kind of want to switch
pieces maybe this is like should be a
new variant you could switch that knife
for the bishop you know if they could
switch places then you know White's
probably doing okay now
but unfortunately I mean uh also in the
current position if Andrew he he was
looking in pain for a second spending a
lot of time on the clock he could
potentially plant his Bishop on the
Square so he could do that he could do
that yeah
a few options here he could for example
also go after this Pawn with his bishop
and try and round it up uh maybe now
finally I just want to get this rook in
the game I'm not sure where to go but
this Rook finally breathed some life
breathes some pressure you can try
doubling up here but it does look very
slow doesn't it you know could you try
to go for the pawn immediately I know
it's like super loose put that night in
the middle of the board
hit the pawn although there will be a
bunch there'll be a tactics for example
the pawn might step forward and after
The Rook takes due to a pin on this file
maybe Knight takes porn it gets really
sharp here uh this is a check the night
can't be captured and then this night
would be uh attacked The Rook after it
as well but yeah I mean this is the
stuff going through a ventric's mind but
he needs to move yeah under the minute
now everyone shook in this tough game
against Magnus Carlsen
and the stars in magnus's position the
Black Knight and that beeporn
well well look at that the bishop has
come out to attack the pawn and so we
might be seeing some like insane
complications
I think it was time and this looks good
as well in that last variation we showed
white tonight if it does retreat into
the center of the board it would have
been loose undefended so he's getting uh
ready potentially to defend uh that
square if the white knight retreats to
D4 that's
then going for the black bee Pawn
but Magnus okay he's got a small time
advantage
he needs to keep that black pawn alive
if he wants to win the game speaking to
himself there it looked like even look
like he said come on yeah yeah I
regularly say that's my software in
games yeah just you got this you can do
this there must be a move come on Magnus
also ticking under one minute on the
clock what a game between two legends
will we see a winner is that the most
likely result in this one
if there's a winner it's most likely to
be black right now it's level pawns
again uh after all that chaos all those
sacrifices it's back to normality back
to equality but uh I mean if that black
bee Pawn disappears white has chances to
win
the way it might become a draw
eventually is if you imagine the knights
disappearing from the board the Rooks
disappearing and then it's opposite
color Bishops why it has a light Square
Bishop black as a dark Square Bishop
they could just kind of neutralize each
other just pass by and so that's the way
this game might fizzle out while Magnus
kicks the White Knight so it's
encouraging the Knight to to come to a
square
um I suppose the thing is if it comes
into the middle white has to worry about
the Rook lining up against those there's
a lot of moves that white has so where's
that Knight gonna go I mean bringing it
to the center does seem the most the
mood that white wants to play now
attacking attacking Black's porn
well 30 seconds left on the clock to
take his decision I don't know about you
guys but I tend to get very stressed
when my clock is running less than 20
seconds
if I get under a minute then I just fall
apart I I like yeah comments shaking
mess I watched David and he like you
know he has a couple of seconds left and
he's as cool as anything you know that
way he gave a Jack that's fine okay he's
got to retreat it next move though
um it's that square that Simon mentioned
the C6 Square for white white tonight is
going to go back slightly and uh at
least it's on a nice Outpost maybe it's
gonna sack a pawn in the middle and try
to get his own passport at some point as
well you know that'd be a you know
typical Chucky thing to do so uh the
white Rook is behind White's most far
Advanced porn like this under 10 seconds
I've never seen him this kind of well
very rarely at least seen him this
panicked when he has a very healthy
position the only time you should ever
see Magnus like this is when he's
struggling or losing and do you see
Magnus he's blinking furiously I mean I
don't know where that's a tell but it
just seems like he's super concentrated
he's ready to pounce
Brooke has to move five seconds five
seconds
make a movements Magnus Rasmus I don't
know I don't know
and uh okay the Black Brook does move
keeping an eye on that white knight
the white Knight's protected
everything's protected
the white King still feels a bit poorly
placed though aren't you what's this oh
a tattoo by a ventric taking a pawn
temporary peace sacrifice Magnus missed
this for sure wow and he has to react do
you take this piece back he doesn't even
take the piece back oh look at this they
are both reacting both reacting
massively White's now just to pawn up
what are we missing it's a poem I mean
Black's got very good control here so
it's it's not a simple Pawn uh Black's
night's great everything but he's lost
Magnus has lost his biggest Trump and
his biggest Trump was that past Pawn so
if anyone can win now well it looks like
Chucky has chances but black very active
yeah very active and the event Chuck's
doing you know he's just over protecting
his pieces
The Rook moves and proves itself this is
very good play from Magnus
yeah the hustle is on though Magnus is
up the pace of the game he's started
playing every move instantly after
making a small mistake there losing his
pawn and uh he's really trying to break
through to this white king okay look at
White's pieces it's like Checkers but uh
which we know evanchook is great at all
of his pieces pretty much on light
squares all his pawns apart from one all
on light squares
you know I actually I think I have
impressed by aventric's last moves and I
think Magnus now has the advantage I
mean he has control of the dark squares
his pieces are great they're very
impressed by ventric's last move so I've
got to say oh just I thought he was in
potentially in big trouble but he's
neutralized everything I mean now you
know the knights are coming off as well
I mean I I still think Magnus can win
this one because there's a lot of like
dark squares going on in that position
even though he's a pawn down but uh what
is it about for Magnus now the b-pawn is
off what is the winning
card for active pieces he has to put his
Rook on the second row his Bishop has to
get maximized on the best squares and uh
well eventually taking a step back with
the bishop
again trying to re-route that piece to a
better Square which makes a lot of sense
um I don't know
anyone's game tough game has so many
pawns lined up I mean could those be a
winning card for him yeah the problem
for a ventric is is quite likely the
knights will disappear and then black
can blockade the pawns on dark squares
so they'll all be stuck on light squares
eternally and uh
even if you're one Pawn up here like a
ventric is if they're blockaded on a
certain color complex if they can't step
forward that's why opposite color
Bishops tend to lead to a draw uh if
every other piece is off and this bishop
move this bishop maneuver really
instructive just blocking out Black's
Rook on the second rank
um okay Magnus if he wanted to win had
to keep the knights on which he does
this is so tense I mean uh all three
results possible I reckon
I think maybe more likely that black
will win than white just because uh
Black's pieces are going to be very
active but
okay key moment if Mac does trades off
these pawns I reckon we're headed
towards a draw if he leaves them on the
board
if you pushed his Pawn down one square
further that black H Pawn
could be a potential winner okay
for setting up some traps that black
knight is not actually entirely stable
porn defending it could be
dislodged at some point
but the Knight jumps into activity there
as well so uh
it's uh yeah it's very very close this
game all the way and he's clearly
clearly playing for the win but that
last movie as you said David just uh not
exchanging keeping pawns on the board
and if black can ever win White's Pawn
in the corner of the H Pawn then uh
he'll probably win the game now so uh so
risky it is very risky not wanting a
draw at all yeah it is risky but I mean
are we going to see a situation where
it's difficult for white to move for
peace
to know why it still wants to push his F
Pawn forward now that black is
controlling the dark squares if white
can put his pawns on dark squares he'll
fight for that control
I think that's a ventric's next move if
he gets the opportunity White's f-born
stepping forward one square suddenly
yeah real threats you really want to
create counter play when you can if you
can move the F Pawn and the one next to
it you get your own pass pawn and I I
know white would love to just get rid of
Black's Pawn that is blocking his Pawn
if that makes sense but you know that
one lined up with The Rook so he needs
to try and blast that one away somehow
and he's going for it yeah he's pushing
forward and then you can see you can
certainly see a van trip when in that
position if he can push push the other
Pawn next and is it better now to have
the pawns on the dark squares yeah
you're fighting for control over that
color complex also I mean this one is it
a strength or weakness in an end game
it's gonna drop off it's just going to
be picked off by uh White's Bishop so
that's why black has to keep the Rooks
on the board okay he drops his Bishop
back he's coming from a different angle
now to start checking this white king
I have no idea who's gonna win this one
I've got to admit the white king steps
back that's clever there's no check on
this square with the bishop because the
White Knight defends it and uh maybe
safe for now it's hard to get this
Knight back into the attack to be honest
the Black
Knights back with his Bishop because
it's time for white to start moving also
maybe that Bishop can now come and
harass White's pawns so it's like
dangerous that you know both sides can
have very dangerous pawns though I think
this is going to be a decisive game I
think he's just gonna look for it it's a
race
quicker though for example if white
takes a pawn black will take a pawn
white steps forward black takes a pawn
with track white is about to make a new
Queen but Black's also making a new
Queen it's just a race someone who are
going to see this type of thing happen
it's chaos on the board incredible and
he's winning here it's anyone's guess
okay Magnus actually doesn't want to
enter into that race he just drops his
Knight back uh in the current position
and he stops this white Pawn advancing
this white Pawn is covered for now and
they have to calculate this race with
less than 30 seconds on the clock Ivan
shook what is his next move
he has to deal with the threat of Bishop
takes porn because that is coming and
this is an excellent move by Magnus
because that night as well as lying up
the white past Pawn is also got an eye
or towards the white king and wow
look attacks the night I think it's like
who whoever's Pawn is going to be more
dangerous here and it it does look like
somehow it should be magnus's I feel in
the corner
um but Chucky's got his pawn two squares
from queening as well right uh they're
both for a short time
he's banking everything on that black H
porn he's about to promote to a new
Queen but it can be stopped by White's
Bishop only way to stop it and now he's
just got to get rid of that bishop and I
I don't think that Bishop's gonna
survive is it it can step forward one
square but then we take the palm of our
rook and uh I can't I
I don't know where that Bishop's gonna
hide I can't see the bishop hiding the
problem as well is that
you have to you have to do something
before that black porn promotes it
promotes with chat there's a brilliant
move you can play Rook you yeah you
could put the Rook on to see too wow
let's get the starfish evaluation
stockfish moves up uh because I think
your ranker might be right there might
be only one move to survive everything
else loses white has to retreat his Rook
to the second rank four seconds
will he find it have you made a move
just in time the genius Yvonne shook wow
look at Magnus he was like oh actually
that's pretty cool
does he have any time on his clock maybe
it's just a small delay here we'll see
his clock time refresh in a second the
idea is that when the Black Rook takes
the white Bishop White's Rook is just
going to give itself up
I mean it's still
to get rid of that black porn with some
drawing chances I guess if you do that
um so we might have the same thing here
he's throwing in a check first and he's
okay
okay now we get this weird ending
we did not predict saying this is
winning for Magnus this is winning for
Magnus here you can win the white Rook
you could have look at Magnus what is
this he just realized he could have won
the white Rook The Black Queen could
have gone to the B3 Square check the
white king Winnie the white game over
Suddenly It's still winning but he has
to work hard again he has to win it all
over again back to square one what
I mean that's maybe not the most obvious
opportunity taking that point As Natural
but yeah he realized as soon as he
played the move yeah it's like you said
Ivanka when you you play a move and you
know you miss the you just missed the
really simple winning move and there is
the way I mean the way you try to draw
it is it's just if you've got the minor
pieces which is white and I mean the
mighty pieces of the rook and the night
you just got to make sure they're close
to each other defending each other you
need to have the king defending the
Knight the Knight defending the rook and
just try to keep them around each other
try to keep some kind of blockade uh but
Magnus doesn't really believe in Block
Haze does he
um so it's it's also that extra Pawn
that could be very important probably a
winning ending this but I'm not
convinced I say Pro
presumably the black king can kind of
come round the edge of the board and
then and then hopefully the queen can
join in and give a check I mean we're
going to be here for a long time we will
be here for maybe a hundred mover
um I think it's there's no tracks no
matter where you pick up the black queen
you can put it on any square of the
board there's no safe checks
just got to be careful your work so um
is make sure the Rook is on a safe
Square
yeah I don't know how you break it down
I mean you've got to try to move the
black king forwards at a safe moment
but even moving the black king forwards
is not going to be easy that's cut off
yeah and uh just while the players
maneuver and Magnus trying to make
progress white trying to keep a fortress
maybe we just show that last bit again
because it happens so quickly
um it was this moment we mentioned that
uh black made a new Queen he took off
the white Bishop actually here white
could have just retreated his Rook stop
the pawn from promoting and Adventure
could have uh probably don't be doing
pretty well he took this Rook off the
board black made a new Queen we saw a
capture and this is the moment Magnus
nearly threw that tantrum and kind of
got really angry with himself because
here instead of taking the spawn he
could have won instantly by giving a
check
check and you win The Rook next move
and now he's having to work super hard
again all back to square one and uh
instead he took this pawn and uh if we
catch up with the current position
what do you guys think
still winning or do not I don't know if
it was ever ever winning to be sure I
don't know if it is winning but the
black king has moved a little bit
forwards but now there's a problem with
that pawn
um how does he defend that Paul under
some tricks involved you can't lose a
pawn I would have thought if you're
going to win this one maybe you can I
mean you could maybe yeah maybe you can
try this move and then attacking this
Knight but the problem is you get
checked back forced to retreat but he's
got his King to the square now and that
King in front of the black the pawn in
front of the black king should I say I
feel is the target Magnus needs to go
for how is a queen and two pawns not
winning against a knight and one porn
it's a good question it should be yeah
if it has a rook as well so yeah and a
rook yeah if we do a count so uh rook
and Knight worth eight uh and they're
facing basically a queen and pawn the
other two pawns cancel each other out so
that's worth ten a queen and pawn so
it's 10 versus 8.
should be winning we think but the
problem is how do you get through to
this white king there's no checks
because Knights are a king's best friend
the Knight keeps the King Super safe the
only way is to at some point push upon
uh I mean either you win white porn for
free with the black queen not easy to do
or you push upon and the problem is in a
situation like this this Pawn might get
located at some point
um it's not easy to achieve right now
but uh I guess there might be a rook
check and uh White would go and win this
Pawn I mean it's just it's just hard to
make progress black in the end moving
the queen across you're right higher at
this position
in logical in a logical world this would
be completely winning for black but
chess is not always logical
unfortunately there are exceptions to
every rule do you think Magnus sitting
there feels he should win this game
he's determined he knows he missed that
opportunity to win White's Rook uh now
for example he's hoping to create a
passport and he's hoping that this porn
will win the game for black
that was a very clever move that check
um that Magnus just played in he's
forced the white king now to pass the
square and if the Knight White's night
is really the the key defensive piece
and I think Magnus is going to use his
Pawn to divert that Knight away and and
when he does that it does seem like it
should be winning okay so after the
trade upon suddenly the table base this
in-game database where everything has
been worked out came into force and uh
well his last move was a mistake his
Rook move and uh now upon this position
black can actually win for reasons I
don't know but he could actually put the
queen to D5 and that would have been a
win after this move it's a draw but
still not an easy draw I mean this is
the kind of move I think you mentioned
David at one of magnus's favorite moves
you allow a discovered check so wherever
the Knight moves the black king is in
check but he's not worried about it
because the White Knight doesn't have
anywhere fantastic but you can't go go
to any old Square you can only draw by
moving the Knight to the D2 square or
the D4 Square
that's it anything else you're going to
lose yeah so anywhere in front of the
queen is the drawing idea but even that
to draw that I mean I would assume this
position is completely winning if I look
to this I'd be like how old that's a
losing one no yeah Knights on the edge
of the board I mean this one also looks
odd yeah I mean the Knight is almost
trapping itself I guess it's gonna go to
this F5 Square which we which we
normally love but but this is like the
beauty of Chess and like the Wonder at
all antagonist's natural king move that
was also a mistake and now the position
is only drawn this is evil I mean table
based computers we should explain to
some of the viewers who are maybe new to
just what table base is it's when I
think there's seven pieces or fewer and
that has been worked out just
mathematically by computers uh they've
worked out what the best moves are for
each side on every turn so objectively
with best play I'm not sure is it still
a draw it's still a draw now draw yeah
like Simon Says from a human point of
view this just looks winning you have a
queen you have a pawn if the pawn wasn't
there sure sure but with this Pawn
it needs to be a way to push it and this
is the thing if I think if black cow or
what he can push it now but it gets
captured if I'm trick maybe he's found
oh uh a way to draw maybe this is the
drawing idea if this Pawn is pushed
lovely yeah this Pawn needs to push at
some point to win the game just gets
taken and queen takes and a pin skewer
and uh eventually we'll see King versus
King and a draw so you've got to push
this Pawn at the right moment when it's
safe
but the thing is now the white king can
always threaten to come forwards and
with the white king coming forwards
you're really containing that pawn so I
it might be a blockade uh that that
we've got here in this position
um give a track and repeat the position
if Andrew does this he checks the King
has to go back and he'll repeat uh okay
the King goes back in a different way we
should also mention that taking this
Knight is a draw uh it's king and porn
but the white king is safely in front of
the black opponent so study your king of
porno games this one is a draw you just
need to know where to go with the white
king uh so Magnus won't go for this
the current position it's all about this
G3 swear right yeah
so this is probably why that king move
was a mistake by
the King on the G line
go around again yeah I was gonna say
exactly the same thing this the king is
in the worst Square
um if you can get the king to avoid that
trick you might be able to push the pawn
this is uh and he's trying it so he's
trying to get the King around now at
some point that black pawn
maybe can come forwards right yeah if
you can push it Forward safely he's
going to win Magnus but okay like check
discover check apparently still safe
still a draw
wow he's really defending uh like a lion
here van trick he's going to drop his
Knight back and he's just gonna sit
maybe maybe he's waiting maybe that's a
fortress yeah yeah what a weird setup
though you you you're like you've gone
into your shell here haven't you you
know you're comfortable that's it
armadillo you know get into the ball No
One's Gonna Get me armadillo yeah that's
a friend's thing again
Simon hasn't watched The Full Monty I
found out today either oh I haven't no
maybe tonight I thought that was uh you
had to do that in school in England or
something yeah I think it's a very
English film right so yeah maybe not
primary school I guess
it came out when we were at University
right so that's our excuse I think uh
isn't that like one of Magnus Carlson's
favorite movies of all time probably
I've never discussed it I think but uh
meanwhile this Fortress continues
evandrick he did it kind of the long way
around he brought his Knight the whole
way around the board but he's found the
ideal defensive Square for it but Magnus
doesn't believe in fortresses
they do they certainly do so how many
moves have we got David because they're
all in chess is uh if there's no capture
so that means no pieces are are taken
off the board or there's no porn moose
if you have 50 moves that happen like
that the game is a draw so um that could
well happen here because there's no
reason at all Magnus will agree to a
draw they're gonna have to play it out
because obviously white can make a
mistake uh Black's last pawn move the
last pawn move or capture was move 72
right so uh so we've got
1322 yes to get to before a draw can be
claimed so it's about to be moved 90 so
we'll have 32 moves left wow if vantrik
needs to survive 32 moves without
allowing a capture of one of his pieces
or the black pawn from pushing yeah but
Magnus is like trying everything you
know if the if the black king can at the
right moment come maybe one square
forwards uh then it'd be potentially
winning if the black porn can step one
square forwards it'd be potentially
winning so there's still danger here but
Chucky seems to know what he's doing
it's a Chucky Fortress you know no one
gets through a Chuck Fortress Yeah what
he has to kind of maintain that
configuration so the only the only few
moves that he can play is that moves the
Knight to the G3 Square yeah and uh
Magnus giving a check
oh this looks good scary
kind of again curl itself up again and
defend the night Rook goes to G2
this is like a type of Fortress where
the the gate like the door is made of
straw or something yeah like at any
moment someone could just burst through
but definitely right now it's it's just
about holding and you can only really
move the Rook up and down one square
maybe the king but I look so risky
um self-pinned you are it's but it's
holding it's holding doing the job
the White Knight is stuck so white has
to play around with his Rook chalk
Fortress is the only Fortress you can
get what I mean great defensive Play-Doh
by by Chucky isn't it I mean we we know
that magnus's
uh the well probably the best end game
player in the world and and Chucky is
holding him yeah only three players have
been able to uh get a draw against
Magnus Carlsen in this Tournament of
course that loss against Neiman Let's uh
not take that into account so if one
should be the fourth player to get a
point against Magnus Carlsen
and Magnus seems to be running out of
ideas he's moving his King around but he
he's a bit unclear what he's actually
doing with this can white just continue
waiting
my fruit can step up what throat can
maybe step across I'm not sure how
narrow the margin for error is right now
I can tell you there's only three moves
and this Rook move was correct if you'd
move the Rook maybe off the G line you
would have lost wow that yeah that's uh
insane sorry is Reiki I was very tempted
to move it over one square yeah me too
and uh but that was losing was it yes
or months of analysis to go to a deep
dive of this one but okay um event truck
is uh trying everything's nice I mean if
the black king can move one square
forwards that also looks like to me
should be waiting for black uh or nearly
winning it's an important moment here
just to kind of say to you guys because
if you step back with the Rook to G1 he
would have lost this he still maintains
The Fortress it's okay and uh yeah he
here he has to move his Rook along the
second row he can also defend the Rook
with his King and it's still a draw you
know so
that's the evangelic here is just
playing great chess he's defending like
a lion and let's just see what move on
remember if we get to move her we have
reached move 100 it's a super long game
the other games in round
um what is it round uh 11 correct has
started we're gonna jump into Neiman
aronian when this one finishes
I think I was thinking kind of a really
good point you made Queen and pawn
against Rooker Knight it should be
winning right but if we think about it
white has two pieces black has only two
pieces I mean let's discard the Kings so
white has a Rooker Knight they're both
pretty good yes the queen is better than
the Rook but White Knight is better than
the black porn so it kind of makes some
sense I guess that white is uh just
about holding here of course the queen
is the best piece and I think in
Practical terms 90 something percent of
these games would end in a black win but
remember this is kind of the top one
percent of chess players in the world
this is the elite and if it if it's
objectively a correct draw then
Adventure I mean so far he's done a good
job of proving that 20 moves to go he's
just you know he's done 30 moves already
so if he can do another 20 moves it will
be a drop just be uh called a draw and I
guess so the thing minus Crossing would
have to do to win this game would would
be to to get the white pieces out of the
eye line of that pool yeah if he can
somehow kick the white Pieces away I
think that's why as Ivanka mentioned the
narrow uh the narrow path to survival
for white is just keeping this white
formation this defensive formation of
antrix found is perfect for stopping
that black pawn but if he can kick the
Pieces away or catch them at a moment
where they're kind of imbalance uh kind
of off balance
um then pushes Pawn himself then he
might win but if not then
Fortress and draw
I think if Andrew deserves the draw is
this one just for his defense I think
he's played it perfectly as well I've
been in so many little opportunities
which I didn't realize that you've
pointed out yvanka where you can just
play one slightly bad move as white and
you you lose your Fortress but he hasn't
done that he's he's kept this harmony
between his three pieces but it really
is like an animal in his shell isn't it
here you really are just sort of moving
about in that shell trying to keep the
defense against the attacking Queen here
and here he goes I think he's gonna hold
it right I think he's going to hold this
drawer it's looking like he's found a
good way and he's navigating those traps
uh very very quickly and very easily as
well but still I still think it's a long
long road ahead of him but Magnus
doesn't look like he's talked to Mystic
anymore he'd made some kind of gesture
there as if he's giving up giving up the
winning attempts
and okay the Knight moves Magnus hasn't
made any progress we should mention for
those last 35 moves so will we see that
draw soon and this game it's had like
five or six different phases it's like
the opening phase the middle game battle
the Queens came off it was still kind of
half middle game half end game but just
the way the players kind of transition
and still so accurate it's impressive
and evantrix built up two and a half
minutes on the clock as well as we
should mentioned uh he was down at a
couple of seconds not that long ago so
he's very confident right now I'm not
sure what else black can try as well I
mean black Magnus has tried everything
he's put his King on the other side of
the Pawn on this side of the pawn he's
trying to force his way through but uh
Chucky has stopped him at every hurdle
so just don't blunder now Chuck in you
can you got this you got this and I
think it was quite instructive on his
last move white just pushed his King to
the side he didn't go after the black
pawn the white Rook could have actually
stepped up check a couple of moves ago
and taken that black porn but black uh
White would have lost all coordination
the black king would have come in now
the black king is cut off by the white
Rook it's so important these positions
they need to keep keep your knight
broken and King all defending each other
you know when you're playing against the
queen you've got to keep your pieces
close you've got to keep them defending
because they can drop off very very
easily uh if you if you try anything too
too much and he's doing that he's done
everything we've seen this position
before right
no I mean if we see the position repeat
itself three times I think the game is
automatically made a draw uh by the
server so
um yeah I mean we've seen something very
similar at least
and if ventric is is that the adrenaline
is he shaking his foot is that
respecting the whole computer vibrate
so full of energy
at a sprightly 53 years old
and uh yeah he's defending this one
still very well you can give a check
with the white Rook for example here
and can you push the Rook over to in
front the king maybe get that get that
Fortress position again as well it would
also be a draw also checking the king
with and the Knight would also be a draw
but of course you have to be prepared to
set that Fortress up again
um yeah this is pretty much quite a few
moves draw it's not such a narrow path
it's an attack the black queen with a
white rock as well Evancho do you reckon
he's just counting in his mind how many
moves it's been his memory is very good
yeah he could be working out yeah often
the top players they they can scroll uh
on the on the computer screen and they
can check when the last porn move was
made but often they just kind of Play
and play and they just believe in their
defense they don't worry about the 50
move or in Rapid Chess at least of
course only only 10 moves now 11 11
moves maybe to be totally accurate but
he's got to just survive for 11 moves
without a capture or a pawn push so we
can count them down now okay he's
getting closer getting close ten moves
to go
do you have another track or go and
attack the black queen with the white
Rook
those look like the most natural
he's looking back we've seen the black
king in this side of the board before
yeah
and uh Magnus just he'll look to try and
set one final trap I don't see it to be
honest he's tried everything already
yeah but uh what a high quality game
true grind like a grand master game yeah
I mean Magnus is doing the right thing
never give up chances just if you have
the advantage no risk try and play for
the win like maybe 10 games out of 100
he would have beaten a ventric here but
that's still a decent percentage
yeah this one is headed towards the draw
though
we'll still be in the lead in their
head-to-head score in Rapid chess 15
wins before this game and 13 for Magnus
this will probably put another draw on
that list
and seven more moves seven more moves
after Black's 120
if the game will be automatically a draw
unless there is a pawn push
okay the Knight moving
slightly surprised by that one but it
looks like the Fortress is still intact
it's still holding it I think the Knight
can always come back I guess as well and
there's not long to go now and I think
Magnus must realize that let's move 122
so
good thing that's a check otherwise you
would lose because it's a nasty night
Fork there but uh you are checking the
king there so just uh
it's good
yeah I mean how narrow is the path now
you might could not narrower at all any
king move any Rook block is going to be
a draw and he chooses to make the Rook
move
and King comes
forward let's see how this one works out
yeah I think we've seen something
similar at least before the white king
is doing a great job of protecting both
of its pieces at the same time
five moves we've been counting down five
reaction from these two when the game
finishes
it's lasted now for uh 70 minutes almost
120 move coming up or was that 120 so
maybe it's only three moves now or two
moves so I can't count black makes three
moves it will be a draw a draw now at
this point you can almost nearly blunder
a piece as long as black doesn't have
time to take it before the 102nd uh be
risky blunder a piece and try to press
the draw button really quickly
I had a rook and Bishop versus rooking
game my opponent made 49 moves and then
blundered his Rook on move 50 but before
I had time to take it I had to make my
50th move and take it on the 51st and he
claimed the drug playing the drawer and
uh he couldn't pretended he did it by
accident
okay the game unless I'm coming wrong it
should be a draw after black after
Black's move now maybe Chucky wants to
play on a little bit no Chucky
it is a draw after
123 moves in 17 minutes two legends in
chess the great was live on shook with a
sigh of relief he gets a draw against
world number one Magnus Carlsen a great
game